He, like a lot of other people in that period—1560s or 1570s—
had already come to question a number of the Aristotlean assumptions about things.
Now according to the doctrine bodies fell with a speed according to their weight—
this is where Galileo starts.
Then he began wondering about, well, how do actually bodies move and can we tell.
I used to, in front of my class, take a couple of balls and drop them in front of the class.
And I'd ask the members of the class, "What do you see?"
And most of the students coming from engineering or science said,
"We see ball or bodies accelerating in free fall."
I would come back at them eventually and say,
"Now, I didn't ask you what you were told you were ought to see. What do you actually see?"
And if you try it, you'll find that you don't see much.
You see the hands holding the ball.  You see the hands opening.
And you hear a thump or a couple of thumps on the floor, but you don't see anything.
And this in part is one of the points that Galileo starts.